some of Larry Nasser's alleged sexual
abuse victims are demanding that the
state of Texas take action against two
legendary gymnastics coaches the former
gymnast claimed that Bella and Martha
Karolyi knew about the abuse and did not
try to stop it the couple ran a USA
gymnastics training center in Texas for
nearly 20 years
Omar Villafranca is in Austin where the
women planned to speak out later today
Omar good morning good morning more than
250 women and girls have accused Nasser
of sexual abuse and many say it happened
at the karoli ranch here in Texas well
today some of those women planned to
hold a press conference here in Austin
urging the State Attorney General to
take action we're not backing down we're
not going away former gymnast Jamie
dancer and Jeanette antolín say they
were sexually abused by Larry Nasser for
years often while training at the karoli
ranch in Texas we're going to keep
fighting until the right people are held
accountable for the mistakes they've
made the ranch site of the USA
gymnastics training facility is now
closed but there are still questions
about what trainers Bella and Martha
Karolyi knew and when they knew it they
had to have known they knew everything
else about everything else we were doing
if they didn't know that we were being
abused they still knew that a grown man
was coming into a child's room at
nighttime by himself
last month the Corollas filed a lawsuit
against USA gymnastics and the US
Olympic Committee seeking damages and to
not be held responsible for several
civil lawsuits filed by Nasser's victims
the Corollas claim they did not know
about allegations of sexual abuse
against nasser until after the 2016
Olympic Games asked a different question
but that contradicts this sworn
deposition from May of last year in it
Marta Karolyi
appears to admit USA gymnastics
president Steve penny warned her in 2015
about Nasser's abuse
were you ever advised by any US agfa
in or around June June of 2015 that they
had received a complaint that dr. nasir
had molested a national team gymnast at
the ranch yes I did and who reported
that to you ma'am we stat pending in a
statement parolees attorney said
multiple objections were made to the
question during the deposition adding
she misunderstood the question
and misspoke I believe that she's lying
I think she's backpedaling now because
she now knows that she is in deep water
like now she's exposed herself of
knowing what was going on we reached out
to USA Gymnastics and the u.s. Olympic
Committee but they would not talk
directly about the karoli case the
Walker County Sheriff and the Texas
Rangers are both investigating those
allegations and plan to turn their
findings over to a district attorney
Nora
all right Omar thank you so much